and Olivia we should say you join us
literally join us tonight
hot foot from the set of your other
queen job qe2 in the crown yeah and
where are you are you nearly finished or
feels that nearly it's the end which
feels like the longest bit you know and
we've been going for months yeah yeah
you're nearly there and for you because
it's me that because of the way this is
happening you're basing it on kind of
two people there's obviously the real
Queen Elizabeth yeah so then are you in
any way having to be a continuation of
Claire for my first few weeks I was just
trying to do an impression of Claire so
I was thinking what would care do now is
sort of so busy I've forgotten so I
might not be doing anything like the
Queen or Clare no because you're you're
the mobility of your face is not
something that our lovely Queen shares
[Laughter]
it's quite hard well so if other
characters are saying something that's
sad I can actually can't hurt myself I
go what the Queen does she is our rock
not awfully this not often not not
caught on camera yeah and so they film
quite a lot on the back of my head on
those days and also they've come up with
a trick so they give me an earpiece and
they play the shipping forecast to me
just have to try and tune in to the
shipping folks I'm not really listening
for my fellow actors I'm just trying not
to listen to them that's good we'll
remember that when we watch it yeah I
hope you can finally hear it
[Laughter]
[Music]
you